répondre
l inter
reversé boulet
bah pour moi
aviez vous même avant
on
m
à
je suis très angoissé beaucoup de mal à
vous répondre
vous avez une pauvre voix et vous me
voler ma seule soirée de repos seule
soirée de relâche
vous avez eu la gentillesse de la
consacrer aux téléspectateurs qui sont
là derrière qui vous regardent et
voyez-vous ils sont très contents de
venir chez vous parce que ils ont
l'impression qu'ils vont pouvoir entrer
en contact avec vous autrement que
derrière la scène où vous êtes là dans
vos éclairages avec vos musiciens vous
êtes complètement réduites à leur merci
là vous êtes payés de vente et oui vous
est envoyé c'est pas trop grave
ouvrage est j'espère je crois je pense
que tout ira bien de ne jamais parce que
si vous demandez trop dont le nom vous
en demandez à peine on vient juste très
rapidement chez vous je pense qu'il est
bon de dire que nous sommes chez vous à
paris mais on va préciser l'endroit
exact parce que vous auriez demain 200
jeunes gens et jeunes filles qui
demanderaient les autographes à la porte
alors disons que vous êtes entre
l'étoile et le bois de boulogne on va
pas plus loin et vous êtes là dans un
grand appartement qui se trouve au rez
de chaussée un grand appartement où vous
ne venez pas souvent d'ailleurs puisque
vous voyagez beaucoup oui assez et vous
avez tout de même l'occasion d'y passer
mais c'était mon appartement a toujours
l'air ça fait 2 du nom roulotte vous
savez on a toujours l'impression de
partir en voyage
j'aime bien qu'aidé mal qui traîne dans
un coin ça soit pas complètement neu blé
je veux pas avoir l'air d'être installé
quelque part avant vous tenez un palm
pre complètement alors oui ma qu' il
manque toujours quelque chose car vous
voulez pouvoir avoir la possibilité de
la rangée toujours à nouveau copain sam
je ne veux pas voir là d'être installé
quelque part je veux pouvoir déménager
ça me plaît eh bien écoutez avant que
vous ne déménage et on va jeter un coup
d'oeil si vous voulez là de l'autre côté
du couloir il ya une grande salle à
manger et dans cette grande salle à
manger un monsieur qui attend en a pensé
à mon père qui est ce monsieur rené
bourgeois et il est là depuis cinq
heures de l'après-midi jouer la taille
attend toujours d'ailleurs
il m' attends toujours il est charmant
et les chantiers mais je n'oublie pas ce
qu'il ne dit rien et on lui avait dit de
venir ce soir
et puis il est venu à la télévision vous
accaparer on a fait une petite
répétition
oui mais maintenant qu elle fait recette
facile
dites moi on va faire un petit on va
jeter un petit coup d'oeil aussi dans la
cuisine si vous voulez la cuisine la ya
aussi des amis fidèles ya ma cuisinière
de ma petite femme de chambre est ce que
vous pensez que le service est difficile
j'ai vous face ils s'adaptent est
affreux parce que parce que j'avais des
oeuvres possible évidemment je me pousse
à 6h du matin je viens d autres vous
vous levez très tard en faisons un
emploi du temps qui est totalement les
jeunes maintenant ça va c'est pas ce
qu'on appelle servir en maison
bourgeoise
aujourd'hui tout c'est tout à fait le
contraire dites moi vous êtes donc là en
ce moment vous êtes là depuis quelques
semaines à paris tout de même et même
quelques mois car votre dernier grand
voyage vous amener en amérique
oui et puis vous êtes rentré en france
et vous êtes à paris même depuis neuf
semaines je crois neuf semaines
il est une chose assez rare on va
demander à bruno coquatrix bruno
coquatrix s'il vous plaît on a notre
direct
ça fait très officiel ça nous a menti
pour une heure le directeur hervé sa
vedette qui hélas est d'abord et avant
tout seul vrai dire quelque chose sur
brunes ou non pas qu'on va lui faire des
compliments parce que je sais qu'on se
fasse que toujours des échanges de
politesses et ça je le pense pas mais je
voudrais dire que des fois où jeune
vedette qu'elles n'ont pas connu les
directeurs d'avant et que ce directeur
là qui est là et un directeur comme j'ai
jamais rencontrées dans ce qu'il est
vraiment très gentils on a l'impression
de travailler en collaboration nation en
association c'est de viser le distrait
en association et enrouée est vraiment c
il a toujours un petit mot pour vous
encourager
il est près de sa vedette et même quand
on est malade quand on est fatigué même
pour lui même si on était crevé venir et
ne cessa donc jeunes artistes
engagez vous rengagez vous dans les
troupes de l'olympia ce que vraiment
c'est un directeur formidable et je sais
dit piaf que vous le dites non pas du
tout par politesse mais du fond du coeur
oh oui parce que en cas d'une journée
beaucoup des directeurs et croyez moi
alors écouté puisque nous sommes dans le
domaine de la gentillesse est ce que
vous avez être gentil en sens contraire
est ce que dit pierre fait une bonne
josette c'est pas facile de ne pas être
gentil avec elle parce que c'est une
vedette idéal et je vous dis pourquoi il
est idéal au travail elle c'est
exactement ce qu'elle veut faire
et comme elle le sait avec précision
tout est simple et tout est facile et
alors il ya une autre chose qui est très
rare aussi chez une vedette
lorsque un technicien se trompe ça peut
arriver c'est toujours sa faute à elle
ce n'est jamais de la faute du
technicien et l excuse toujours et ça
c'est très rare on c'est extrêmement
rare et puis alors je crois aussi que l
on va vous permettre de faire un même
programme pendant neuf semaines chose
qui ne s'était jamais vu chez vous
jamais ça je dois le dire et elle le
fait elle l'a fait non seulement avec
avec beaucoup de courage parce que c'est
une zone très dur ça représente un
effort considérable mais avec une bonne
humeur avec une gentillesse que j'ai
même pas toujours moi-même quoi qu'elle
en dise mais si mais si mais si m mais
qui est réparé puisque elle un jour de
relâche et qu elle le consacre à la
télévision si vous continuez à cette
offre il était très fâché du reste
enfin je vous promets que demain ne sera
plus en jeu droit
nous disions donc que vous êtes depuis
neuf semaines à la fia mais vous êtes
depuis plusieurs mois à paris car vous
avez tourné un film et je crois vous
êtes content que vous aimez bien faire
du cinéma j'aime non jeu c'est à dire
j'aime bien faire un film de temps en
temps mais je n'aime pas je n'aimerais
pas le métier de cinéma ah ben on
comprenait mais parce que je crois que
c'est surtout le metteur en scène et qui
est un pas quel travail intéressant pour
les artistes et pas toujours très
intéressant oui je vous comprends merci
lui mai 2010 metteur en scène tandis qu
on les responsables de tout ce que de
deux scans de ce congrès de ce que l'on
choisit mais là cependant je crois que
vous avez été très content oui très
content parce que j'attendais que dans
celle d'estelle et puis le scénario et
d'un de vos amis deuil
une pierre brasseur oui aussi été adapté
par jacques sigur alors là une équipe
nous a menti ne tourne avec michel
auclair un mot mestral joël bernard des
tags et bien écoutez je pense que ce qui
serait bien c'est d'en présenter à bruno
coquatrix et aussi à vos amis vivent
derrière là un petit extrait de ce film
et je pense qu'il serait bon que vous
essayez nous situer un petit peu ce que
nous allons voir on va voir une scène
entre vous et armand mestral c'est une
scène assez versatile et oui pourquoi
est elle aussi très bien au départ c'est
ce ménage ne s'accorde plus et la femme
se met à boire
le mari la trompe et il ya une scène
violente parce qu'elle vient de le voir
rentrer évidemment d'un rendez vous il
ya une scène assez pénible entre eux
c'est la scène que vous allez voir eh
bien la voilà à vous télé cinéma